düstere aussichten für die wirtschaft
die bundesregierung rechnet infolge der
korona krise mit der schwersten
rezession der nachkriegszeit ins ausland
besser nicht wegen der pandemie
verlängert das auswärtige amt die
weltweite reisewarnung
die branche fordert hilfen anklage mord
der rechtsextreme stephanie muss sich im
fall des kasseler regierungspräsidenten
lücke vor gericht verantworten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen wie
heute da beginnt unsere nachrichten tag
mit alarmierenden zahlen aus der
wirtschaft
es sieht nicht gut aus für die
konjunktur vielen unternehmen sind die
umsätze weggebrochen und zu spüren
bekommen dass als erste die
beschäftigten das heißt es wird infolge
der korona pandemie wieder mehr menschen
ohne arbeit geben
dabei hatte sich die wirtschaft nach der
globalen finanzkrise vor elf jahren so
gut erholt damals war das deutsche
bruttoinlandsprodukt um 5,7 prozent
eingebrochen
seitdem aber nahm die
wirtschaftsleistung zehn jahre lang
stetig zu bis jetzt
die bundesregierung schätzt dass die
wirtschaft in diesem jahr sogar um 6,3
prozent sinkt das wäre die schwerste
rezession der nachkriegsgeschichte
heike slansky aus berlin lächeln
zuversicht verbreiten auch wenn die
zahlen bitter sind der größte absturz
beim bruttoinlandsprodukt seit bestehen
der bundesrepublik und trotzdem will der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
mut machen es handelt sich um einen
langstreckenlauf
wir müssen mit unseren kräften
haushalten wir müssen schritt für
schritt vorgehen sonst gefährden wir die
bisherigen erfolge und machen die
konsequenzen gravierender und ein
steigender hunderttausende beschäftigte
sind bereits in kurzarbeit um ihnen zu
helfen hat das kabinett heute weitere
maßnahmen beschlossen
das kurzarbeitergeld soll in etappen ab
dem vierten und dem siebten monat bis zu
80 prozent des lohnausfalls steigen für
eltern bis zu 87 das ganze befristet bis
zum jahresende auch das arbeitslosengeld
soll um drei monate verlängert werden
falls es zwischen mai und dezember
auslief kritik von der opposition
gefordert dass wir das kurzarbeitergeld
insgesamt auf 90 prozent aufstocken
da sollte jeder den kurzer reichlich
egal wie lange das wir dann einen
einkommenssicherung von 90 prozent des
letzten gehalts
vorbehaltlich des gesundheitsschutzes
muss es eine neue vorfahrtsregel eine
neue politische vorfahrtsregel für
wirtschaftswachstum und arbeit geben
denn die menschen wollen gesund durch
die korona krise kommen aber sie wollen
nach der korona krise auch noch einen
arbeitsplatz haben
in einigen branchen geht es langsam
wieder los nach dem zweiten quartal
rechnet die regierung mit einer
allmählichen erholung und stellte für
besonders gebeutelte branchen
bedarfsgerechte konjunkturprogramme in
aussicht die lage ist ernst aber an der
börse spiegelt sich das so gar nicht
wieder valerie haller in frankfurt woher
kommt die relativ optimistische stimmung
naja die stimmungen der base ist ganz
anders als er die von der
bundesregierung über das liegt so ein
bisschen in der natur der sache die
bundesregierung setzt ja darauf dass
sich die wirtschaft nach corinna relativ
schnell berappelt in ihren zahlen ist
auch keine zweite infektionswelle
einkalkuliert ob es allerdings wirklich
so schnell gehen kann daran zweifeln
hier doch einige unternehmen müssen sich
in der krise massiv verschulden müssen
diese zurückbezahlen und werden daher
erstmal sparen müssen
das bedeutet kaum investitionen kaum
neue jobs eine längere durststrecke
außerdem gibt es noch viele
unwägbarkeiten vor allem für den
deutschen export an der börse ist man
viel optimistischer als die ökonomen das
viele geld der regierungen und
notenbanken wird die konjunktur schon
anschieben das hofft man hier zumindest
die börse schaut mal wieder etwas weiter
in die zukunft wie die aber wird kann ja
keiner seriös einschätzen die erholung
an den aktienmärkten ist also alles
andere als ein indiz dafür dass wir
schon über den berg sind
vielen dank valerie haller an der
frankfurter börse
auch die preise reagieren auf die korona
krise einige lebensmittel sind deutlich
teurer geworden benzin und öl dagegen so
günstig wie lange nicht mehr
alles in allem ist die inflationsrate
nach vorläufigen daten im april deutlich
gesunken
auf nur noch 0,8 prozent im vergleich
zum vorjahresmonat
im märz waren es noch 1,4 prozent
gewesen
alle die einen urlaub fest eingeplant
haben warten sehnsüchtig auf ein zeichen
ob und wenn ja wann und wohin man denn
überhaupt reisen kann
für den hochsommer ist alles noch offen
doch in den nächsten sechs wochen läuft
erst mal gar nicht
die bundesregierung hat ihre weltweite
reisewarnung bis mitte juni verlängert
andreas kühner ist erklärt was das im
einzelnen bedeutet
die tourismusbranche hat die
entscheidung erwartet und gefürchtet in
dresden und vielen anderen städten heute
rettet die reisebüros aber es wird bevor
es besser wird noch einmal schlimmer
dass die bundesregierung die weltweite
reisewarnung erneuert macht
auslandsurlaub in den nächsten sechs
wochen praktisch unmöglich
wir haben nach wie vor die situation
dass es in vielen ländern
einreisebeschränkungen und ausgangs
beschränkungen gibt dass der
internationale flugverkehr am boden
liegt und deshalb ist es notwendig die
weltweit geltende reisewarnung bis mitte
juni zu verlängern
die reisewarnung gilt für alle nicht
notwendigen touristischen reisen
buchungen bis zum 14
juni können ab heute kostenlos storniert
werden ohnehin bestehen in fast allen
der rund 190 staaten der welt strenge
einreiseverbote für touristen und
ähnliche probleme ohne sie
busunternehmer reisebüros veranstalter
in der deutschen tourismuswirtschaft
sehen sich zwei drittel der unternehmen
von insolvenz bedroht es hängen
unglaublich viele arbeitsplätze träumen
es hängt unheimliches volumen dran wir
deutschen sind reiseweltmeister und das
wollen wir auch bleiben
eine aufhebung der reisewarnung ist noch
nicht in sicht sie soll aber eu weit
abgestimmt werden tschechien und
österreich drängeln bereits wie kann die
wirtschaft wieder durchstarten zu dieser
frage sind wir ein zdf spezial gleich im
anschluss an unsere nachrichten und in
der zdf- heute- app können sie jederzeit
nachlesen welche auswirkungen die
reisewarnung hat etwa auf den nächsten
urlaub
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen in deutschland nach angaben der
johns hopkins universität sind stand 18
30 insgesamt mehr als 160000 corona
infizierte durch tests bestätigt davon
gelten mehr als 120000 betroffene als
genesen 6300 74 menschen sind in
verbindung mit dem virus gestorben
einen leichten anstieg mit 1 1441 gab es
bei den neuinfektionen
die regierung will infizierte künftig
schneller finden und testen sagt
gesundheitsminister sparen
künftig sollen auch menschen ohne
symptome getestet werden wenn sie mit
risikopatienten oder pflegebedürftigen
zu tun haben in der vergangenen woche
ist die zahl der tests auf eine knappe
halbe million gestiegen künftig sollen
es deutlich mehr werden
julia schröter berichtet vor einem monat
hatten die korona tester beim großlabor
bios tänzer in ingelheim gut zu tun
es war arbeit am limit seitdem ist die
zahl der tests hier deutlich
runtergegangen
wir haben jetzt in den letzten zwei
wochen so immer etwa knapp unter 50
prozent der tatsächlichen kapazitäten
auch ausgenutzt
bundesweit sieht es ähnlich aus
vergangene woche wurden gut 467.000
tests durchgeführt möglich gewesen wären
aber deutlich mehr etwa 900.000 getestet
werden derzeit vorrangig menschen die
atemwegsbeschwerden haben und entweder
mit einem infizierten kontakt hatten in
einer gesundheitseinrichtung arbeiten
oder zu einer risikogruppe gehören
das soll sich künftig ändern nach dem
willen der bundesregierung sollen mehr
menschen getestet werden
außerdem sollen pflegeheime stärker in
den fokus rücken weil die menschen dort
besonders verwundbar sind und deswegen
wollen wir regelhafte ermöglichen wie
viele bundesländer ja auch schon
begonnen haben
in pflegeeinrichtungen auch bei
symptomfreiheit zu einer testung der
bewohnerinnen und bewohner zu kommen
auch menschen die nicht in einem heim
wohnen sollen ohne krankheitszeichen
getestet werden können
auf kosten der krankenkassen jetzt
müssen wir in eine phase übergehen wo
wir solche menschen testen die entweder
andere gefährden könnten oder die
möglicherweise selbst in die situation
gekommen sind wo sie sich selbst
gefährdet haben und also wo sie sich
angesteckt haben könnten labore seien
künftig auch melden müssen wenn jemand
negativ getestet wurde
je mehr daten desto größer die chance
die pandemie in den griff zu bekommen
schauen wir in die usa wo heute drei
zahlen deutlich machen welch enorme
ausmaße die korona krise für das land
angenommen hat so wurde inzwischen bei
mehr als einer million menschen das
virus nachgewiesen
das ist fast ein drittel der bestätigten
infektionen weltweit
außerdem starben mit rund 58.500 bereits
mehr menschen als bei den nationalen
trauma der amerikaner dem vietnamkrieg
und dann bricht auch noch die wirtschaft
im ersten quartal ein um minus 4,8
prozent rt wissen aus washington
sie donnern über die städte der ostküste
als dankeschön an die helfer oder mut zu
machen
denn amerika beklagt an diesem tag mehr
opfer in der pandemie als im
vietnamkrieg das pentagon denn die
aktion amerika strong das gegenteil von
stark sind die zahlen von heute eine
rezession der größte absturz seit der
finanzkrise 2008 der wirtschaftsberater
des präsidenten befürchtet schlimmeres
den größten schock seit der
weltwirtschaftskrise wir müssen das
ernst der die zahlen der ersten monate
reflektieren nur den beginn der
schließungen im zweiten quartal droht
ein rückgang um 20 prozent mehr als 26
millionen arbeitslose viele stehen an
den kostenlosen lebensmittelausgaben an
monterrey sie ist ein veteran
kriegsversehrte mit einer kleinen rente
vor sieben wochen verlor er seinen job
in diesem restaurant und hat nur noch
900 83 dollar
der wahl schütten farmer ihre milch weg
weil die logistikketten nicht mehr
funktionieren schweinezüchter müssen
wohl bald ihre tiere keulen
denn die fleischverarbeitende industrie
liegt weitgehend lahm weil so viele
ihrer arbeiter krank sind dass die
fabriken wieder öffnen irgendwie hat nun
der präsident befohlen donald trump
verbreitet optimismus
jetzt wo die experten sagen das
schlimmste der pandemie liegt hinter uns
freuen sich die amerikaner auf eine
sichere und schnelle wiedereröffnung
unseres landes
aber ein großteil der bundesstaaten
macht nicht mit weil mediziner den
präsidenten widersprechen die
vorschnelle öffnung der geschäfte sei
ohne eine ausreichende zahl von tests
viel zu riskant zurück nach deutschland
das bundeskabinett hat auch einen
einmaligen bonus für die mitarbeiter der
altenpflege beschlossen steuerfrei
demnach sollen vollzeitkräfte zunächst
bis zu 1000 euro erhalten
diese kosten übernimmt die
pflegeversicherung für auszubildende
sind bis zu 900 euro vorgesehen bis zu
500 euro sollen andere beschäftigte
bekommen
physische distanz strenger hygiene
regeln kita kindern ist das schwer bis
gar nicht beizubringen
trotzdem soll die kinderbetreuung in den
nächsten wochen und monaten wieder
anlaufen in vier phasen ganz behutsam
darauf haben sich die familien minister
von bund und ländern verständigt
bisher gibt es nur eine notbetreuung für
in corona zeiten besonders wichtige
berufsgruppen alexander eschment
berichtet zum ersten mal seit sechs
wochen kann durch airbus ihre kinder
wieder zur kita bringen
sie und ihr mann arbeiten in den
systemrelevanten berufen für die berlin
die notbetreuung ausgeweitet hat
ich habe irgendwie die ganze zeit
versucht das gut hinzubekommen ist
irgendwie köchin putzfrau
arbeitnehmerinnen mutter lehrerin ich
habe noch ein kind in der schule bis
jetzt in der schule und ich habe
gearbeitet 35 stunden die woche
so geht es vielen eltern dabei können
kitas wie hier in berlin westend merken
aufnehmen als derzeit in der not
betreuung sind mit raum teilung
hygieneregeln so wie früher und
spätdienste doch sie dürfen es nicht
wir können s anbieten und würden glaube
ich eine menge eltern mehr helfen können
auch in der zeit weil für die ist das ja
auch ein stressfaktor wenn die angst
haben ihren job zu verlieren die
familienminister der länder sehen die
notlagen
sie wollen in vier schritten zum
regelbetrieb zurückkehren nach jedem
zwei wochen lang das infektionsgeschehen
beobachten
grundsätzlich empfehlen die minister
hygienemaßnahmen und tagesabläufe
anzupassen gefährdete personen besonders
zu schützen und kinder und eltern mit
besonderem bedarf vorzuziehen
wann es soweit sein wird ist offen man
kann eben noch nicht genau für jedes
bundesland einen genauen zeitpunkt
festlegen sondern hier muss schrittweise
vorgegangen werden die bundesländer
werden das jetzt auch noch mal beraten
gemeinsam mit der bundeskanzlerin
denn auch bei den kitas hängt alles
davon ab wie sich die infektionszahlen
entwickeln kann sich die hoch
verschuldete hauptstadt trotz trotz
drastisch eingebrochene fluggastzahlen
noch zwei flughäfen leisten
nein sagen die gremien berlin tegel soll
nun ab spätestens juni für zunächst zwei
monate geschlossen werden offen bleibt
schönefeld für den antrag haben
aufsichtsrat und gesellschafter gestimmt
derzeit nutzen pro tag nur noch etwa
1500 passagiere tegel statt 70.000 zuvor
der flughafen muss mit der eröffnung des
ber ende oktober ohnehin schließen und
das werden viele berlin reisende sehr
bedauern denn tegel ist überaus beliebt
was heißt das denn jetzt für fluggäste
und für die hauptstadt cars carsten
behrendt
ja das bedeutet eine große umstellung
tegel ist ein flughafen an dem viele
emotionale hängen das ist ja auch ein
flughafen der mitten in der stadt liegt
also der für die geschäftsreisenden auch
schnell den weg zu terminen bringt aber
sechs bis sieben millionen euro verlust
jeden monat das war einfach jetzt so
viel für die flughafengesellschaft und
deswegen hat sie nun die reißleine
gezogen und diese temporäre befreiung
von der betriebspflicht beantragt der
aufsichtsrat hat zugestimmt in der
gesellschafterversammlung hat der bund
noch bedenken angemeldet
trotzdem insgesamt die
flughafengesellschaft darf das jetzt
machen und es bedeutet natürlich auch
dass die sommerferien wenn man denn da
fliegen könnte
dass die dann von schönefeld laufen
werden die flüge denn von tegel dann in
dieser zeit nichts und ja wenn der br
dann ende oktober ans netz geht dann ist
eben die große frage wird tegel
überhaupt noch mal eröffnet und diese
frage konnte und kann der flughafenchef
heute nicht beantworten ja sagt er hat
keine glaskugel und weiß nicht wie sich
die passagierzahl die sich der flugmarkt
zeichen der korona pandemie weiter
entwickeln wird
die große umstellung kommt er auf alle
zu vielen danke carsten der mord am
kasseler regierungspräsident walter
lübcke erschütterte im juni 2009 10 das
ganze land
die tat hatte einen
rechtsextremistischen hintergrund da
sind die ermittler sicher weil lübke
sich als cdu politiker für flüchtlinge
einsetzte wurde er getötet
gegen den mutmaßlichen mörder stephanie
und einen möglichen komplizen hat der
generalbundesanwalt jetzt anklage
erhoben
felix zimmermann mit den details anfang
juni 2009 10 vor seinem wohnhaus wird
der kasseler regierungspräsident walter
lübcke erschossen
eine dna spur führt zum mehrfach
vorbestraften rechtsextremisten
stephanie der gesteht zunächst die tat
begründet sie mit rechtsextremen motiven
doch später widerruft er das geständnis
nicht er sondern sein freund markus h
habe lübke an seinem wohnhaus erschossen
angeblich aus versehen
der generalbundesanwalt schenkt ihm
keinen glauben und hat nun anklage
erhoben
gegen stephanie wie in heimtückischen
mordes gegen markus h wegen beihilfe zum
mord zwar sei dieser nicht am tatort
gewesen habe aber den part im
schlusspaar stephanie bestärkt die
ermittler sind doch überzeugt dass
stefanie für einen messerangriff auf
einen iraker im jahre 2016
verantwortlich ist versuchter mord
lautet die anklage
stefanie bestreitet die tat die
erwartungen an den kommenden
strafprozess gegenüber den fall wittke
hinaus wir verbinden mit dem prozess die
hoffnung dass auch die strukturen die es
in der nordhessischen neonazi szene
gegeben hat und die schon bei der nsu
untersuchung aufgefallen sind dann mit
aufgeklärt werden stefanie hatte an
rechten aufmärschen teilgenommen war
mehrfach einschlägig vorbestraft ob er
und markus hamer teil eines
rechtsextremen netzwerks waren ist
weiter zweifelhaft zentrale akten die
die frage beantworten könnten sind für
jahrzehnte unter verschluss
doch auch im strafprozess werden offene
fragen etwa dazu ob stefan verbindung
mit der terror organisation eines uhr
hatte wohl nicht beantwortet werden
dort geht es allein um den nachweis der
angeklagten taten mit einer
prozesseröffnung vor dem
oberlandesgericht frankfurt wird ab juni
gerechnet
in einem anderen fall hat der erste
prozess begonnen da geht es um ein
ganzes pädophilen netzwerk das im
vergangenen jahr in bergisch gladbach
aufgedeckt wurde
angeklagt sind zunächst zwei männer
ihnen wird vorgeworfen zwei kleine
mädchen über jahre hinweg schwer sexuell
misshandelt und die bilder in einem
pädophilen chat verbreitet zu haben
insgesamt ermittelt die polizei gegen 65
verdächtige es war das erste dauerhafte
kz der nationalsozialisten und ein
grauenhaftes modell für viele weitere
das konzentrationslager dachau bei
münchen
genau 75 jahre ist es her dass die
amerikaner dem morden dort ein ende
bereiteten
ein güterzug voller leichen ist das
erste was die soldaten an diesem tag
sehen
nur ein bruchteil der vielen toten die
sie hinter den mauern finden
insgesamt hielten die nazis hier 200.000
menschen gefangen 41.500 überlebte das
kz nicht heute stille trauer und eine
warnung luther sonne wald die
gedenkfeier zur befreiung des kz dachau
musste dieses mal ohne überlebende zeit
zeugen stattfinden
man dürfe das größte
menschheitsverbrechen der welt niemals
vergessen mahnte bayerns
ministerpräsident bestimmt tief in der
schulter modelte
wir stehen in der schulter überlebende
und wir stehen in der schuld künftiger
generationen
die soldaten ihr leben wollen und denen
wir es immer gemeinsam verhindern ist
heute vor 75 jahren wurde das
konzentrationslager dachau von der
amerikanischen armee befreit mehr als
40.000 menschen waren hier zwischen 1933
und 1945 qualvoll zu tode gekommen
rund 32.000 häftlinge überlebten das
grauen
einer von ihnen war der damals 16
jährige ben lässt er hat zuvor die kz
auschwitz und buchenwald überlebt in
dachau wurde er schließlich am 29
april 1945 befreit mehr tot als lebendig
[Musik]
plötzlich hörte ich befreiung befreiung
die amerikaner die amerikaner
einige häftlinge krabbelten auf ihren
händen und knien und küssten die stiefel
der amerikanischen die 1
einer von ihnen der damals 19-jährige
denn partie
wir machten eine schreckliche entdeckung
die waggons eines zuges gefüllt mit
bergen von völlig ausgemergelten
menschlichen leichen
wir waren erfahrene soldaten die gelernt
hatten mit tod und zerstörung umzugehen
aber auf so etwas kann man sich
unmöglich vorbereiten
die kz gedenkstätte dachau erinnert an
die opfer des ns regimes und wir
vermitteln wohin ausgrenzung
menschenverachtung und rassismus führen
können
[Musik]
mit schlechten zeiten für die deutsche
wirtschaft haben wir begonnen mit guten
für einzelne unternehmer hören wir auf
es gibt nämlich auch die deren produkte
in der korona krise plötzlich gefragt
sind strandkorb hersteller zum beispiel
in buxtehude jedenfalls stehen die
kunden schlange für urlaubsstimmung im
eigenen garten reisen an die küste sind
ja zurzeit kaum möglich und da ist es
wohl der eigenen strandkorb der bei
akutem fernweh etwas tröstet noch
tröstliche wäre womöglich einen
lottogewinn
hier sind die zahlen für sie sie lauten
1 57 32 36 41 und die superzahl 9
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 5
57 zum wetter da gibt es regen und
gewitter und das kann auch mal kräftiger
ausfallen mehr hat gleich gunther
tiersch so viele von uns für den moment
danke für ihr interesse
darüber würde sich auch christian
sievers freuen nachher im heute journal
und wir hoffen dass sie auch morgen
wieder mit dabei sind um 19 uhr einen
angenehmen abend für sie es
[Musik]
und am liebe zuschauer der april
verabschiedet sich windig kühl und
wechselhaft da komme aus westen
südwesten so mäßig warme luft die bringt
immer wieder kleinere regenfronten mit
sich diese eine wird uns heute nacht und
auch morgen tagsüber überqueren und
morgen abend da liegt schon wieder die
nächste von frankreich vor der haustür
bei uns heute nacht regnet es auch noch
anfangs im osten ziehen ein paar schauer
ab danach wird es erst einmal trocken
aber in der zweiten nachthälfte beginnt
es im westen wieder zu regnen die
temperaturen sinken dann meist auf sechs
bis zwölf grad am alpenrand nur auf vier
grad und dieser regen der nacht im
westen der zieht dann am vormittag schon
mal hier in die mitte deutschlands
während es im osten noch freundlich ist
da kommt die sonne raus und der wind
wird kräftig und stark zum teil auch
stürmisch und nachmittags erreichen dann
diese schau auch den osten teilweise als
gewitter dahinter lockert schon mal
wieder ein bisschen auf aber hier im
südwesten
da setzt dann am späten nachmittag
wieder kräftiger regen ein
dafür wird der wind schwächer und die
temperaturen bleiben aufwerten wie heute
etwa 13 bis 18 im osten 20 oder 19 grad
im südöstlichen bayern wechselhaft geht
es weiter immer wieder schauer und
gewitter stürmisch am freitag und am
samstag erst sonntag beruhigt sich das
wetter
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
und machen sie es gut